-Hello, everyone, and welcome
back to the Captain's Quarters.
I have now been trapped inside
without an audience since March,
and, as some of you have
noticed,
that I've gone a little insane.
Weird things have been happening
to my hair,
I befriended the wasps
in my attic,
And for some reason I even went
on a lengthy and irrelevant rant
about a 20-year-old TV show for
teens, "Dawson's Creek."
-You know what they say, Seth.
A creek is just a tiny ocean.
-[ Chuckles ]
Who would say that and why?
Oh, right, I've also become
friends with a talking painting,
and by the way, I'm aware that
the Sea Captain character
has been divisive.
Some of you love him.
Some of you hate him -- Dad!
Some of you are just confused as
to why we've chosen to invest
so much of our time and energy
into this bit.
So, we have decided to settle
this debate
once and for all with a poll --
Should we keep the sea Captain?
Yes or no.
To vote, just log on
to www.google.com,
type in Sea Captain,
but don't click search,
take a screen shot,
print it out,
write yes or no or it
with a Sharpie,
and then mail it to wherever
your best guess is
for the address I'm filming
the show at.
We will reveal the poll results
at the end of the summer.
-The only pole I'm interested
in is a fishing pole.
-Jokes like that aren't
helping your chances
of sticking around, Sea Captain.
-Okay.
-Speaking of psychosis,
President Trump and his allies
in the right-wing media
are once again amplifying
an unhinged viral video
lying about the coronavirus.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
As the coronavirus pandemic
has spread out of control,
so has misinformation about it.
If you have Facebook,
or an uncle who still wears
his class ring,
you've probably heard
some of it.
I'm pretty sure we've all gotten
at least one e-mail
from a relative during this
whole thing
with the subject line like...
...when we all know that
swallowing a candle
and sticking garlic up your butt
is number three on goop's
top 10 ways
to relax on a job interview.
And it won't shock you to learn
that a lot of the misinformation
can be found on Facebook,
the Website you signed up for
just to see
if your high school crush
got married to that
son of bitch, Jeff.
Well, A -- they did,
and B -- they also went crazy.
A report in April collected some
of the most popular
coronavirus myths circulating on
Facebook.
Some examples include...
There was a post claiming
you can hold your breath
for 10 seconds to test yourself
for coronavirus
and another alleging that
someone named Dr. Mario Pesaresi
had revealed that inhaling steam
is a natural remedy for
coronavirus.
Well, if steam cures disease,
that would finally explain why
all New Yorkers on subways
look so hale and hearty.
The L train is more restorative
than an Icelandic spa.
Second, I don't know
who Mario Pesaresi is,
but he sounds like a doctor
Paulie Walnuts
would be friends with on
"The Sopranos."
"What's that smell?"
"Oh, that's me, Ton.
Dr. Pesaresi told me if I put
provolone in my pants,
it would cure my you-know-what."
"I don't know what."
"I got a genital discharge."
"Ohh! We're eating here!"
By the way, if you're offended,
you should know
the writer who wrote that
is Italian-American.
-Ah, Italy, the New Jersey
of Europe.
-So is the writer who
wrote that.
Mwah.
Now, you've probably heard some
of the more infamous
and ludicrous conspiracy
theories
like the idea that 5G mobile
towers are spreading coronavirus
or that it was created
by Bill Gates
as a way to implant chips
into people through vaccines.
Unfortunately, these ideas
aren't just confined
to dark corners of the Internet.
They often make their way into
the real world
as we saw in April when
right-wing conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones showed up to
an anti-lockdown protest
in Texas.
You remember Alex Jones,
the guy who always looks like
he's trying to Hulk-out
but can't.
I think because instead of gamma
rays, he was hit by ham-ma rays.
-I like it.
-Jones led the crowd
in chants of
"Arrest Bill Gates."
[ Crowd chanting
"Arrest Bill Gates!" ]
The only police who should
arrest Bill Gates
are the fashion police.
Bill, why can't you find a tie
that goes down to your waist?
You look like the assistant
manager at a GameStop.
You and Trump need to split
the difference.
You're an I.T. billionaire.
Stop dressing like an I.T. guy.
And then there are
the viral videos,
which might seem at first lance
to come from reputable medical
professionals,
repeating some of the wildest
debunked conspiracy theories
about the origins or effects
of COVID-19.
Like that infamous
"Plandemic" video,
featuring Syosset Stevie Nicks,
a person who claims,
among other things,
that masks can somehow
"activate" coronavirus,
that beaches
shouldn't be closed
because they have restorative
properties that cure diseases,
and that...
Which is ridiculous for many
reasons.
I mean, if the guy could create
a highly-infectious virus
in a lab as part of
a secret plot
to sell a money-making vaccine,
don't you think
he could also learn
how to throw a baseball?
And then there were those two
Urgent Care doctors
from Bakersfield, California,
who falsely claimed
in a viral YouTube video
that the virus just wasn't
as deadly
as most other experts believed.
They based that claim on some
extremely faulty data,
which they arrived at through
some truly terrible math.
Basically, they claimed that a
lot more people in California
had been infected with the
coronavirus,
which would make the percentage
of cases
that result in death
a lot smaller.
And they arrived at that
conclusion, in part,
by taking the rate
of positive tests
at the clinics they own
and just extrapolating that rate
to the entire California
population,
which makes no sense.
The people who walk into an
Urgent Care clinic
because they think
they might be sick
aren't a representative sample
of the entire population.
I mean, I know I've definitely
gone to Urgent Care
like four or five times to ask
them about a weird rash
and been told it's just
New York skin.
Could be bedbugs.
Could be a rat bite.
Could be heat rash from having
your radiator
stuck on high all winter.
Could be irritation from a
cockroach in your kitchen
smoking a cigarette.
[ Inhales ] "I'm your new
roommate, and no,
I won't wear a mask.
We need to get organic soaps."
As one biologist --
"I'm sorry.
I draw the line at soaps.
As one biologist who specializes
in infectious disease modeling
put it,
the doctors' method was...
Which is ridiculous.
You can't estimate the average
height of Americans
from the players on an NBA
court.
However, you can estimate the
average basketball skill level
of Americans from the players
on the Knicks.
In both of these cases, those
videos are not just seen
by millions of people before
being taken down,
they were also
amplified by right-wing media.
The Sinclair Broadcast Group had
planned to air an interview
with the star of "Plandemic"
this past weekend
until it backed down
after an outcry.
Although, even in their
statement
withdrawing the segment,
they also seemed to defend
their initial decision
a little, writing...
That's not a justification
for saying
whatever you want
without consequences.
You guys love to talk about the
marketplace of ideas,
but actual marketplaces are also
free to impose their own rules.
Because if you just let everyone
and everything
into the marketplace,
you get Etsy.
"Happy birthday, Mark."
"Oh, a dream catcher...
made of old... Fresca cans.
You...shouldn't have."
And I'm not saying free speech
should be regulated
by the government,
but we can do things
like, say,
break up big-tech companies
so they don't have so
much monopoly power.
Also, a marketplace of ideas,
just like a marketplace
of goods,
should be responsive
to criticism.
In a real marketplace, you can't
just open a store
called "Arsenic-fil-A"
or "Toys R Us
and Us Toys R Knives."
And then say, "You can't
criticize me.
It's the free market."
Dangerous misinformation
like this has been surging
during the pandemic,
often with the help of prominent
figures on the right.
The latest example
is a Facebook video
staged and funded by a
right-wing dark money groups.
The video, which was viewed by
over 20 million people
before being taken down, claimed
you don't need to wear a mask
because the anti-malaria drug
hydroxychloroquine
is a cure for coronavirus,
even though it's been repeatedly
disproven by study after study.
Just last week, there was yet
another study
published in the
New England Journal of Medicine
which found that
hydroxychloroquine
does not help COVID-19 patients.
No drug has been studied this
much
since those troublemakers
at Psi U conducted an experiment
to see which strain of marijuana
makes DORITOS taste better.
I hope you're happy, gentlemen,
You've all flunked out.
And believe me, we all wish
hydroxychloroquine
actually worked.
We wish everything worked.
Everyone wishes there was a cure
for coronavirus.
No one wants to be trapped
inside for this long.
If hydroxychloroquine really
worked, I'd take an UberPool
to Times Square to get coughed
on by a tourist
just for old times' sake.
Ah, Times Square...
Where else in the world
can you get...
M&Ms?
I can't wait to be first in line
at my local bodega ordering
a bacon, egg, and cheese.
Well, no, with my luck,
I'd be second in line
behind a construction worker
placing their order
for his entire crew.
"[New York accent] On the fish
sandwich, I need
pepper and a light hot sauce."
[Normal voice]
I miss you, friend.
I've cursed you under my breath,
but I do miss you now.
But all the studies tell us
hydroxychloroquine doesn't work,
and pushing it is dangerous,
especially --
especially for people
who actually need it for
conditions like lupus.
After the President began
touting hydroxychloroquine
for coronavirus
earlier this year,
lupus patients struggled to get
it with one telling "USA Today"
that because...
That's horrible.
Lupus patients basically have to
microdose a life-saving
medication the same way
your recently-divorced aunt
microdoses LSD.
"If I take the right amount,
it's almost like Steve never
existed in this universe."
And yet, because they've failed
on the pandemic response,
and because they're desperate
for a magic fix
that will make the
crisis go away,
prominent figures on the right
are now pushing the discredited
hydroxychloroquine video.
The President's son, Don Jr.,
had his Twitter account
partially locked for 12 hours
after tweeting the video
to his 5 million followers.
And then last night, he went on
Fox News to complain.
-Now, Twitter takes me down
for that,
but twitter has no
problem saying that coronavirus
disinformation spread by the
Chinese government
does not violate their rules.
That's interesting.
Jake Tapper himself
a few weeks ago posted,
"Study finds hydroxychloroquine
helped coronavirus patients
survive better."
Now, why is Jake Tapper not
spreading misinformation
but I somehow am?
-It's fun when a dumb guy brings
printouts to an interview.
It's like when the jock on
campus carries around a book
to impress girls.
"Oh, this?
Yeah, I was, uh, just reading
about my favorite author,
Ernest Hemingway.
He went to jail.
They, uh, made a movie
about it."
Oh, wait, wait.
I'm sorry,
what's on one of those
printouts?
Oh, man.
-What is it? I can't see.
-Ah, n-n-nothing.
And by the way, there's a huge
difference between a journalist
tweeting a link to a news story
and what you tweeted out.
At least he tweeted a link to a
reputable news organization
reporting on a study that put
the findings in proper context
and used cautious language,
whereas you just tweeted out
a video
funded by a right-wing
dark money group
with a doctor calling
hydroxychloroquine
a "cure for coronavirus."
A doctor, by the way,
who also claims that,
"gynecological problems are,
in fact, caused by people
having sex in their
dreams with demons and witches,"
that "alien DNA is currently
used in medical treatments,"
that "scientists are cooking up
a vaccine to prevent people
from being religious,"
and that the government is run
in part not by humans but by
reptiles and other aliens.
"[As Paulie] Hey, Ton,
I figured out
where that discharge came from.
I had dream sex with a demon."
"[As Tony] Ohhh! We're still
eating here!"
[Normal voice] "Demon sperm"
sounds like a catchphrase
on "Church Chat" after dark.
"[As Dana Carvey] Look at you
with your throbbing
loins and pulsating buttocks.
Is it possible you're infected
with, hmmmm-uh,
could it be...[echoing]
demon sperm?"
[Normal voice] [ Sighs ]
Side note --
I'm very close to having early
1990s Dana Carvey hair,
although I'm even closer
to Dennis Miller.
Oh, man.
Have those '90s Miller locks?
That's the dream.
-Back to The Look, Jocko!
-See? He serves a purpose.
Also, if they were really using
DNA in treatments,
Trump definitely would've asked
Fauci about it.
"[As Trump] Fauci,
just spit-balling here,
what if we got an alien
and just let it attach it
to your face?
You know, like a big hand?
I'm hearing very good things
from my friends
at the Weyland-Yutani
Corporation, Fauci."
[Normal voice] Seriously, does
she actually practice medicine?
Filling out those insurance
forms must be a nightmare.
Have you recently
one -- traveled abroad,
two -- visited a farm,
three -- boned a demon?
Seriously, who on Earth
could possibly trust
a doctor like this?
Oh, God...
Why'd I ask?
-There was a woman who
was spectacular in her
statements about it,
that she's had tremendous
success with it.
And they took her voice off.
I don't know why they took her
off, but they took her off.
I can tell you this.
She was on air,
along with many other doctors.
They were big fans of
hydroxychloroquine,
and I thought she was very
impressive.
-I was very impressed with
her and other doctors
that stood with her.
I think she made sense.
-Cool, so, Trump won't
listen to the renowned
infectious disease expert who
actually works for him
but he loves
the demon-sperm lady.
Was he like this when he lived
in New York?
Because New York is filled
with people like this.
If you go to a community board
meeting,
there's always at least
one demon-sperm guy.
That's how you know the meeting
is ending.
"Alright, we have time for one
more issue.
Yes, you, sir?
"Yeah, I got a question.
Uh, what are we gonna do
about the demon sperm on the
statue in the park?"
"Sir, for the last time,
that's pigeon poop."
"That's what Azazel wants you
to think!"
"We're adjourned."
Although, I guess Trump
is used to hearing crazy stuff
from doctors
since this guy was his doctor.
"Hey, man, you want to try this
alien vaccine
I've been working on?
It's here somewhere.
Soy sauce packet, soy sauce
packet, honey mustard.
Oh, here we are, cocaine.
Oh, did I say vaccine?
I meant cocaine."
Dangerous coronavirus
misinformation
is surging on social media,
and it's being
amplified by the President
and his backers because they
know their response
to the pandemic
has been a colossal failure.
Just step back and consider how
insane this is.
The President can't be bothered
to focus on the things
that actually work --
like testing, contact tracing,
isolation, or mask-wearing --
but if a crazy person
posts a video
claiming lizard people are
making alien vaccines,
his response is --
-That's interesting.
-That's The Look, folks,
and I...am...out of here.